well first I can hardly believe that I'm
standing this john lasseter thank you so
much for this this incredible honor
thank you to my wonderful producer Anson
you my vxf of my VFX Supervisor Derek
flood my composer Jack Urbina
to our amazing hard-working team many of
which are here today to our generous
IndieGoGo supporters of course to the
accounting of art University and to the
mentors that really have helped us like
guided us every step of the way we
couldn't have made it here without you
two of which are in the audience today
diane baker and patricia [ __ ] thank
you
and last but not least thank you to my
friends and family who my gosh
had to deal with me when i was neck deep
in this extremely addictive but
rewarding work i also wanted to mention
what an incredible week we've had this
week this entire week of just industry
events and festivities organized by Sean
Cooper and Hector Garcia
I think they deserve another round of
applause seriously meeting all of you
the members of the Academy the veterans
of the industry professionals and fellow
lovers of the Arts it has really opened
my eyes to what and where I want to
aspire to be and it also has taught me
that you know hard work actually
sometimes and oftentimes more so than
talent wins the day and I think each of
you are you know sitting here because
hard work shows that you know that
you're durable and that you've wanted
this badly enough and sometimes in
itself hard work is its own reward which
was definitely the case for soar I am
definitely and we are all at the
beginning of a long road and it's the
first step and I can only stand here and
thank you all so much for being here
tonight for supporting my team and me on
this first step which I hope is the
first in a very long journey thank you
so much